hey everyone it's Mike bottles and guess
what I got another webinar coming up on
Friday we also with investor inspiration
I did one last week with investor
inspiration and you have to keep asking
me back so I must be doing something
right
and what are we talking about in this
presentation is what I call inside of
the traders mindset you know it's
something that doesn't really get
discussed very much you know everyone
likes to talk about oh this is how I
trade this is how you should follow it
but you know what every trader every
person is wired a bit differently and
there's different reasons you know
people come into trading what makes a
person good at it and you know what are
some of the common themes or
denominators in the people that trade
well that are successful what are they
and I'm gonna be discussing that again
this is something I really haven't gone
into very much before in public and you
know this is something that I think that
will benefit a lot of people you know
normally I talk about very specifically
on order flow and so I'm trying to widen
you know widen the umbrella make it a
little bit more a cover more people
because again you know this is
information I've learned over 20 years
trading at you know firms like JP Morgan
a cargo comers bank and even the floor
that's you know most traders don't
really think of so you could register go
to my website the link is actually below
in the description or you could go to
WWF lows comm slash register dot html'
now take you to a page and just click on
the link there sign up and ultimately
the sign up page looks like this just
enter your name and your email phone
number I think you could leave blank
anything else you don't need to give
your phone number unless you don't want
to and there's actually you know six
other speakers actually a total of six
speakers I'm the last one but there's
actually two other people talking about
order flow immediately before me Lee
Harris from the emoji trading who is a
good friend of mine we'll be talking
about support and resistance in order
flow but the first one here Randi
Lindsey you'll be talking about market
direction using the volume and price and
I think that would be an interesting one
it's you know it's a bit of I think
price action and I don't say order flow
per se but you know when you start
dealing with volume you start running
into order flow and you know one of the
things that he'll be discussing is
using volume as an indicator for
signaling price movements prior to them
happening so I think that's gonna be an
interesting one as well so it's actually
you know quite a few nice ones you know
you got Aaron Vincent and Jonathan as
well but you know again you know if
you're really into Oracle and you want
to learn more I think that you know
today or this Friday's presentation will
be very beneficial to you not just from
what I'll be talking about and Lee
Harris but also you know Randy so again
you know be being a good trader is about
you know taking the information you know
taking the knowledge from other people
disseminating it taking the parts that
resonate with you and putting it into
your trading method so what will I be
talking about specifically is you know
the first topic I'll be talking about is
so you want to be a trader and you know
now how people really understand this
question everyone says oh I wanna start
trading so I want to make a lot of money
honestly when I started trading you know
I had this end dream it wasn't even a
goal it was a dream at the time so yeah
I just want to be able to sit on the
beach you know in my shorts sipping
mai-tais putting on a couple trades in
the morning and that's it like that and
then go swimming with the pretty girls
but you know that I said that that's not
a plan that's a dream and you know to
become a successful person in the
trading industry you have to really
formulate a plan yeah yeah you're how do
you get from point A to point B I mean
where are you now
where you want to be five years from now
ten years from now what is your ultimate
goal and what are the steps you're gonna
take to get there okay again when I
started in the industry it was a lot
easy more easy than it was than it is
nowadays right because there was a
training floor there was a cm e floor
there was a cbot floor and you could
just go down to the floor and get a job
you know now it's a lot harder to get a
job you have to have a certain
background you know a certain degree and
in you know and you have to know how to
program and you can still get it become
a trader but you know the sort of the
path to entry the goalposts have shifted
you know it's it's become it's different
it's just just the landscape has change
and that's just the way it is so you
know you could still trade for yourself
there's nothing stopping you from doing
that and again you know the barriers to
entry are very low but you have to ask
yourself what do you want to get out of
trading you know again you know some
people they say I want to make lots of
money okay you can
but what are the steps you're gonna take
to get there the second thing I'll be
talking about is understanding that
there's more to trading than just having
a trading system you know lots of times
people will buy a system it'll buy
system for me even and not make any
money at it because they don't
understand what really they think just
buying the system is gonna make them a
lot of money you know like y'all just
can put on my computer and I'll be come
through my computer into an ATM machine
ok that's it really work that way you
know there's more to trading than just
having a training system you know you
have to understand yourself as a person
you know you have to have some form of
self discovery understand you know your
risk tolerance levels you know your fear
levels your greed levels and you know
once you understand that then everything
starts to fall into place and you can
form your own method of trading you know
yes you can use a trading system but you
have to form it into you know it's part
of your overall trading plan on Venus a
good trader being a successful trader so
you have to understand yourself just as
much as understanding the markets
understanding you know the method that
you're trading the third thing I'm
talking about is what it really takes to
be a successful trader and you know I
see this goes in life as much as trading
you know to be good at something you
know it takes practice you know right
now we're in the middle of the Olympics
and you see these guys these kids out
there and I call them kids because
they're L 1718 winning these gold medals
and snowboarding you know why is it
because you know they're dedicated right
they put in the work it's not like oh
you know I'm just gonna you know play
snowboarding no you know they dedicate
themselves you know Michael Phelps you
know he's a great great athlete great
Olympian the swimmer
you know never read his biography every
day for how many years even on Christmas
he's out there swimming putting in you
know how many hours a day of training
you know and that's the dedication you
know it takes hard work just you know
even if you own a construction company
right it takes work it takes dedication
to what you're doing you know if you say
you're an uber driver right you're going
to work more because you're gonna make
more so you know and why is that this
goes if you're dedicated and you work
hard yes you can become successful but
just
working harder at something doesn't
necessary guarantee you're gonna be
successful you have to understand the
different how to say it all the
different little steps involved to
becoming a success in anything in life
rather than just thinking oh one day I'm
gonna wake up hey I'm gonna be a trader
like all these guys a perfect example
all these guys buying Bitcoin or these
cryptocurrencies
you know when the markets going straight
up nobody's asking any questions about
anything goes all you gotta do is just
buy you just close your eyes by like
that and I was on these guys think that
they are market Wizards because they
just happen to catch a move you know
they just and some people just happen to
fall backwards into a position and in
Bitcoin years ago and just did nothing
about it you know 50 cent right there
the rapper turns out he's got like six
or seven million dollars in Bitcoin
because you know a few years ago when he
launched his album he accepted Bitcoin
okay yeah however many bitcoins for him
and he just left it there because at
that time it was worth nothing you know
now when it was discovered that he's got
all these millions because the Pitt coin
everyone you know I'm waiting for other
people say Oh 50 cent he's such a great
trader you know he did this years ago
and look at him now
you know no that's just sort of you know
falling into it right it wasn't part of
his plan that hey you know I think
bitcoins gonna go up so I'm gonna take
the other thing you know but you see
that a lot with you know if some of
these Bitcoin guys is you know they just
sort of bought into it and you know
caught them move up and now that it's
come down you know 50% 60% you don't
hear about how great you know how great
they are as traders you know it radio
silence on that but anyway I was trying
to digress a little bit and the last
thing I'm talking about our common
traits of successful traders you know
what they exhibit on a daily basis now
I've had the very good fortune of
working with many of the best traders
and investors in the world again I'm not
saying that say hey look at me I'm a
great person no you know I mean I found
myself in positions that I daily phone
calls with some of the guys that you
know the the portfolio managers at you
know some of the biggest hedge funds in
the world and sovereign wealth funds and
there are certain traits that they all
sort of exhibit now again I'm not gonna
say that there's five traits that they
all exhibit because you know say there
was five traits that make a list you
know not everyone's gonna follow all
five you'll suddenly follow four let me
follow three but you know there's
certain commonalities among the elite
traders the highly successful traders
that they all they all exhibit in one
form or another and you know people I
said well you know you you know all this
you know why are you sharing it you know
if you should know this you should be a
great trader but again you know it's
about giving you that knowledge making
you understand what it is again it's not
like you know the elite level of traders
that is such a tight community it's so
small that nobody you know if someone
else joins them someone else falls out
no actually when you reach that level of
trading Nirvana you want to call it
trading success yeah it's a very big
space up there there's room for
everybody
and it's not like somebody goes up
somebody else goes down oh it's not like
that you know there's there's room up
there for everybody and that's what I
want to get you you know get you
thinking about what you have to do to
become a better trader so again you
could sign up below in the description
click on the link below you have your
choice either go directly to investor
inspiration or go through my website
again the link is below in the
description so I don't want you thinking
there's two different links it's the
same one you end up in the same place
and go to order flows calm so that's
register dot HTML and it'll take you to
the sign up page as well and best of all
it's free you know this is free
information you know I mean what have
you got to lose except your time you
know you just spend again you know even
if you're working or you're sending the
kids to school whatever cuz you know
this starts at 10 a.m. and goes to about
3 p.m. I understand that you know at
least if you register you'll get access
to the replays as soon as they're
available usually takes them a day to
render them and get them out to people
and this one's on Friday so you might
not get it till Monday but at least you
know it'll be there for you for one you
know when you have the time to watch it
you know do what I do I do a lot of
downloading stuff to my phone I will be
there you know if I can't download it
directly from YouTube or something
I'll just screen captured it and loaded
hunt my phone you know it's my not them
there's a bit of a long way to do it and
I listen to these things you know when
I'm driving or if I'm sitting on a train
or I'm somewhere waiting for something
like in the doctor's office and the
waiting for the doctor I just listen to
these things you know I mean I try to
watch them you know I purchased on my
appetite for taking in you know and
again it's not just trading stuff I
watch a lot of this these other shows on
YouTube I subscribe to and again you
know if if you'll definitely learn
something you know whether it's just for
me or one of the other presenters you'll
definitely get something out of this
this training summit so again you know
go down to the description you can click
on the link there or you go to my
website order flows comm slash register
now HTML and I'll take it directly to
the sign up page so thanks everyone and
hope to see you there on Friday bye bye